die habe ich von lust auf süßes ich muss
ja eigentlich dicht machen
doch egal ich nehme jetzt einfach was
[Musik]
und deshalb mache ich mir jetzt ein
toffifee in xxl größe
[Musik]
und das zu machen ist gar nicht so
schwer ich zeige euch jetzt schritt für
schritt die zubereitung für das karamell
benötigen wir 200 gramm creme fraiche
150 gramm weißen zucker und 150 gramm
braunem zucker
keine angst vorm karamell machen meine
variante ist supereinfach dafür gebe ich
alle drei zutaten in einen topf und
verrühren was kurz miteinander
[Musik]
dann gehe ich rüber zum herd und der
hitze das ganze gebe den deckel drauf
und lass' es aufkochen
[Musik]
nach dem aufkochen schalte ich das ganze
auf mittlere stufe und lass es fünf
minuten lang weiter köcheln wichtig ist
dass dabei nicht ungehört wird mit hilfe
meines thermometers schaue ich danach
wie viel grad das ganze erreicht hat
eine temperatur von 135 grad sind
perfekt denn dann lösen sich die
zuckerkristalle auf ihr bitte vorsichtig
sein denn es herrscht verbrennungsgefahr
und deshalb gebe ich das karamell fünf
minuten lang an die seite und macht mit
dem haselnuss kern weiter
dafür benötigen wir 40 gramm gehackte
haselnüsse und 40 gramm zucker den
zucker lasse ich bei mittlerer hitze in
einem topf schmelzen und gäbe
anschließend die haselnuss kerne hinzu
[Musik]
die haselnuss zuckermasse muss dann
immer wieder verrührt werden und nach
circa ein bis zwei minuten sind wir auch
schon fertig die masse ist auch wieder
sehr sehr heiß also zieht euch am besten
handschuhe an dass das ganze tue not ein
paar minuten stehen und dann könnt ihr
sie zu einer kugel formen den herrn
solms kern legen wir bis zur
weiterverarbeitung an die seite wichtig
ist dass er jetzt für die weitere
verarbeitung eine geeignete form
verwendet ich habe ich ja eine
silikonform die lässt sich super den
auch von hinten habe ich später keine
probleme das toffifee rauszubekommen und
da gebe ich jetzt mein karamell hinein
[Musik]
nun wird das karamell in der form
gedrängt hin und her bis es allmählich
auskühlt und ab rte das kann bis zu zehn
minuten dauern
zur not auch noch ein bisschen mit den
fingern nachhelfen und dann kann auch
schon die mogat creme zubereitet werden
dafür benötigen wir 650 gramm nutella
350 gramm freue mich kuvertüre und 350
gramm zeigt peter kuvertüre
[Musik]
die creme geht jetzt super schnell und
einfach dafür werden alle drei zutaten
in eine schüssel gegeben und miteinander
verrührt
[Musik]
für die zusammenstellung des toffifee es
ist wichtig dass das karamell komplett
ausgehärtet ist in die mitte lege ich
dann den haselnuss kern und darüber die
muss nun bringen
[Musik]
die film wird dann noch einmal schön
glatt gestrichen mit einer winkel
palette und anschließend wird das ganze
noch mal durch gekühlt nach zwei stunden
im kühlschrank gebe ich dann zack peter
kuvertüre obendrauf das mache ich mit
hilfe meiner lochte in kreisenden
bewegungen
[Musik]
mit meiner winkel palette streiche ich
das dann noch mal schön glatt und gäbe
dass nochmal zum kühlen in den
kühlschrank
[Musik]
und schon ist euer xxl toffifee fertig
ihr müsst es nur noch aus der
silikonform befreien das geht aber auch
super easy einfach von unten heraus
drücken
[Musik]
natürlich darf auch das große wiegen
nicht fehlen hier haben wir ein
zuckersüßes kleines toffifee mit acht
leichten gramm und dann kommt unser xxl
toffifee mit 2175 gramm
ich denke das reicht mir ich brauche ist
ein tunnel geht es den letzten tropfen
die macht mir doch egal
[Musik]